tous les étés maximo et moi de
s'arranger pour partir aux célibataires
sans nos fans
oui c'est ça en célibataire à trois on
ne faisait plus qu'un jusqu'à cette
fameuse nuit où on avait dix neuf heures
9h50 à savoir ce qui était arrivé j'ai
tué stèle ya trois quarts d'heure avec
mes mains tu les égorger dont je
l'étranglé
mais ça c'est quoi ça ça c'est l'esprit
et m&t mais t'es sûr qu'elle est aux
[ __ ] simon elle est où il vient de te
dire qu'il a tué guy roux et la
dépouille
il a pas le temps d'organiser les
obsèques beaucoup de pourquoi t'as pas
prévenu les frites tu veux qu'on le
fasse pour toi sinon sera là pour
appuyer je peux parler on tombe je vais
pas mérité ça tu vas y aller mais tu vas
pas y rester
bah c'est tout lui ment pas il va y
rester ce minimum 10 ans simon simon ou
simon revient sur terre tu as tué sa
femme
tap tap a tué un malfaiteur qui entré
chez toi pour te voler vous voulez
m'aider
oui bien sûr un pôle on est évidemment
arrivé à 9 heures commence si je suis
arrivé à 9h que je ne connais pas être
tu veux qu'on mette commente de troy
carter s'est pas beaucoup trois quarts
d'heure enfin je crois pas mais c'est
simon quand même
simon n'est pas une ordure quoi je
serais pas aussi affirmatif
c'est le portable de sony il ya un nom
pascal et quoi commence à pascaline ma
fille qu'est ce que tu as peur
d'ailleurs le plus compétent avec pascal
il répond claire il y avait cette valeur
établie au moins tu voulu prévenir les
flics je suis d'accord comment on
fonctionne je le raconte tout par
téléphone ou jordi juste venait mais je
sais pas moi c'est pour un crime de
pouvoir bénéficier dans l'adresse c'est
qu'est la presse commence à quelle
adresse à la mienne ou celle de simon
rythmer la vie et que tu tenais à gagner
chez toi